bonjour à tous alors il a dit que toutes
les conférences tedx 1 démarre par une
histoire du coup je vais vous raconter
la mienne donc
cette histoire débute en 2006 à l'époque
je suis étudiant et j'ai effectué mon
stage de 2e année donc je suis en jeu a
donc je suis principalement profil
marketing et j'effectue et du coup à ce
stage dans une association à but non
lucratif aux états unis dans la ville de
seattle et ma mission principale lors de
cette mission c'est de créer un moteur
de recherche pour une base de données
donc je connais pas grand chose en fait
dans les langages de programmation et on
est que je suis un profil marketing donc
donc je débute voilà je galère je galère
un petit peu et un beau jour vient
m'aider
du coup un ingénieur en système
d'information et il va en fait débugger
mon code et toute la magie en fait qui
va apparaître ensuite va vraiment
m'étonner est en fait cette magie va
apparaître au moment où cette personne
va mettre en ligne un bon programme via
ce qu'on appelle un serveur est en fait
l'ordinateur qu'ils utilisent
ce qui renvoie à l'écran c'est ça et je
sais pas si vous connaissez ce que c'est
mais en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle le
système d'exploitation gnu/linux levé le
gabon on appelle ça on appelle ça linux
et c'est vraiment la première fois que
je vois justement linux à l'écran et
jusqu'à présent j'en avais un petit peu
entendue comme à la météo quand vous
parle de mistral et tramontane quoi ces
amours comme ça qui vous parle mais vous
l'avez à vous l'avez jamais vu et du
coup j'ai eu une révélation donc
naturellement je vois cet écran et je
veux ma lui poser tout un tas de
questions je dis waouh c'est
impressionnant salaire salaire super
technique qu'est ce que c'est exactement
est ce que tu peux monde m'en dire plus
c'est une des questions que lui pose
c'est au ks salaire salaire difficile à
utiliser
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas et la
réponse qui va me donner qui est
vraiment la clé de toute cette
conférence donc retenez bien du coup à
ce qui ce qui va me dire c'est ça c'est
oui c'est dur c'est difficile à utiliser
donc il parlait pas que de linux y
parlait de un petit peu de l'univers du
logiciel libre en tant que tel dont je
vais vous parler dans cette conférence
mais si tu y arrives en fait si tu
travailles dur si tu arrives à
comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière tu est
assuré d'avoir un job jusqu'à la fin de
tes jours et en fait je suis là
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
j'ai suivi son conseil et
j'attends en fait ce qu'on appelle le i
qui gagne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui je
fais déjà je vis de l'univers du
logiciel libre sachant que je suis
quelqu'un du marketing
je fais quelque chose que j'adore je
suis super bien payés c'est à dire que
généralement je travaille à une journée
dans le mois et mon salaire il est déjà
il est déjà fait et plutôt de bons
salaires
aujourd'hui je fais vivre toute ma
famille grâce à ça c'est grâce au
logiciel libre que j'ai pu rencontrer ma
femme c'est grâce à saab a naturellement
par ricochet que du coup je suis
aujourd'hui l'heureux papa d'une petite
fille qu'à neuf mois et surtout j'ai
l'impression des ddd le monde entier est
également j'ai eu l'occasion de voyager
à travers le monde d'ailleurs je
continue encore à le faire et travailler
pour les plus grandes institutions et
pour les plus grandes entreprises de la
planète alors que que je n'ai que je
n'ai que 34 ans du coup cette conférence
je vais l'articuler de la manière
suivante je vais tout d'abord vous
définir ce que c'est qu'un logiciel
libre ensuite je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi c'est intéressant également
comment rentrer dans ce fameux l'univers
du logiciel libre
alors le mot logiciels libres vous
l'avez probablement déjà entendu et vous
avez probablement déjà utilisé du
logiciel libre en chevaux amis ici
quelques logiciels que vous connaissez
probablement un tel que libreoffice tels
que wordpress tels que gimp ou encore
firefox et je vais vous éviter en fait
tout le jargon un petit peu à technique
de la définition ce qu'un logiciel libre
je vais vous le gard is et tout ça elle
simplifier je veux dire plus en mode
marketing un logiciel libre en fait il
est défini par quatre libertés
fondamentales qui sont la première la
possibilité de pouvoir l'exécuter pour
toutes tâches que vous souhaitez donc
contrairement aux logiciels
propriétaires ou privateurs ce qui va se
passer c'est que vous n'êtes pas régis
par des conditions générales
d'utilisation vous avez signé vous vous
êtes engagé à utiliser le fameux
logiciel juste pour une fin bien définis
par le créateur de logiciels non avec un
logiciel vous êtes libre de faire ce que
vous souhaitez donc ça c'est la première
liberté
la deuxième liberté c'est la possibilité
d'analyser le code source
vous allez dire qu'on a un profil en
marketing ou qu'on n'est pas dans le
domaine de l'informatique quel est
l'intérêt de le faire bah tout
simplement de vérifier s'il n'y a pas
des données qu'ils s'envoyaient à des
tiers vous savez qu'à chaque fois on va
vous parler de vie privée le fait que
certains acteurs vont récupérer des
données que tel logiciel va envoyer des
données à droite à gauche par l'intérêt
d'un logiciel libre c'est que vous
pouvez à tout moment investiguer ski
adam faire rechercher et regarde en
effet six ans voit pas des données à des
entreprises auxquelles vous n'auriez pas
souhaité que ça envoie des données
troisième liberté c'est la possibilité
de voir faire du business avec cette
affaire c'est à dire que vous avez
possibilité de voir prendre le logiciel
de le modifier et derrière de pouvoir le
revendre par la suite typiquement c'est
le cas du world press je sais pas si
c'est un logiciel qui vous parle mais
encore une dizaine d'années on
n'entendait pas beaucoup parlé de
wordpress aujourd'hui c'est quasiment le
logiciel principal que utilisé pour
créer des sites web est aujourd'hui il
ya tout un paquet d'âge ans de micro
entrepreneurs qui ont réussi du coup à
lancer leur activité sans plan parce
qu'ils ont récupéré ce logiciel créé des
sites internet pour des entreprises x ou
y ait derrière revendre en fait le site
internet en tant que tel et le client
lui derrière b récupère un site intérêts
qui lui appartient intégralement et la
4e libertés fondamentales c'est la
possibilité d'améliorer
du coup le logiciel c'est à dire la
possibilité de pouvoir le modifier de
rajouter des fonctionnalités lui faire
faire ce que l'on souhaite
voilà donc si on devait comparer un
petit peu le logiciel libre à ce qu'on
appelle le logiciel propriétaire et et
privateurs d imaginer que le logiciel
libre
c'est comme si vous décidez de
construire une maison vous êtes libre de
choisir le terrain que vous voulez vous
êtes libre de pouvoir choisir les
matériaux vous allez utiliser pour
construire votre maison la taille de
votre maison et que c'était et c'est
lorsque vous utilisez du logiciel
propriétaire ou privateurs ce qui
représente à peu près on va dire pas
loin de 100 % du matériel et des
logiciels que vous achetez quand ben
voilà qu'on vous les achetez dans la
dans le commerce on est vraiment sur un
cas ou à voilà vous êtes locataire
donc vous êtes locataire d'un immeuble
sis voulait percer un trou bas vous avez
palois faut demander aux propriétaires
sous les repeindre les murs vous avez
pas le droit non plus etc etc
donc voilà en fait la grosse différence
entre ce qu'est un logiciel libre et ce
qui est un logiciel propriétaire ou aux
prédateurs alors maintenant je vous ai
définit ce que c'est justement le
logiciel libre je vais vous expliquer un
petit peu pourquoi il est intéressant de
s'intéresser à l'univers de logiciels et
donc il ya quatre principales raisons
que j'ai pu identifier la première c'est
celle qui doit le plus vous préoccuper
c'est ce qu'ils appellent le problème
place code je sais pas combien d'entre
vous dans cette salle ont déjà entendu
parler du problème classe code
ok ça craint mais le programme classes
code
qu'est ce que c'est c'est simplement dès
l'âge de 8 ans
en fait demain les élèves ont la
possibilité du coup de suivre ce
programme vous pouvez taper classe cote
dans un célèbre moteur de recherche et
vous trouverez le site est en fait c'est
tout un ensemble de ressources qui sont
là justement pour les éduquer à
l'univers du logiciel libre est
également à la pensée informatique donc
c'est à dire que dès l'âge de 8 ans ils
ont la possibilité de savoir comment
créer un site web
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet comment
créer un robot comment on crée son
propre programme
exeter et c est ce qui m'a fait flipper
dans ce programme classes code et qui
m'a fait vraiment revoir toute ma
méthodologie de travail toute ma
méthodologie d'enseignement à
l'université c'est le jour où j'ai
regardé ce qu'il y avait dans ce
problème classe code et le jour où je
les comparer à ce que moi j'enseignais à
mes étudiants à la faculté au niveau
master 1 master 2 en marketing digital
et j'ai vu que le contenu c'était le
même
d'accord c'était le même donc à gamin de
8 ans aujourd'hui il va ressortir avec
les mêmes connaissances les mêmes
compétences que les étudiants que je
formais à l'époque donc il ya deux trois
ans parce que maintenant j'ai revu toute
ma méthodologie de travail
donc vous pouvez imaginez le truc c'est
à dire que dans dix ans quand ces gamins
là il faut sortir de l'école avec toute
cette expérience là qui va être majeur
et qui vont pouvoir travailler
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'il va nous
arriver qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va vous arriver naturellement ils vont
vous dévorez vous êtes les dinosaures de
demain ok donc ça c'est vraiment super
important pour vous c'est cessé de
réaliser cette partie là d'aller
regarder ce qui se passe dans problème
kaskod si vous n'avez pas encore ce
bagage en culture numérique
la deuxième raison principale pour
laquelle vous devez absolument vous
intéresser à l'univers du jeu logiciel
libre c'est ce qu'a mis en évidence
justement edouard snowden donc il a mis
en évidence beaucoup de choses mais dans
ce qu'il a mis en évidence un moment
donné à ce qu'on appelle le programme
prisme d'accord le programme pris ce
midi simplement que la msa a accès à
tout un ensemble de services dégâts
femmes y compris comme on le voit ici du
gmail du skype etc et ce cas c est
marrant c'est que quand édouard snowden
il a mis en évidence donc maintenant des
quasiment sur une période de deux trois
quatre cinq ans
le réflexe que le grand public a eu sa
répétées de dégager et tout ce qui est
skype tout ce qui est gmail etc
l'ordinateur non principalement ce
qu'ils ont trouvé comme moyen de défense
c'est ça c'est de prendre un post it et
se dit en fait je vais le mettre sur ma
webcam comme ça on va pas savoir ce qui
se passe dans ma maison
d'accord mais il faut imaginer que ça en
effet ça me permet de savoir que en
effet on vous voit pas quand vous êtes
en train de le faire ou des trucs comme
ça mais
naturellement derrière ça empêche pas de
récupérer tout ce que vous dites
d'accord quand vous utilisez ces fameux
logiciel la troisième raison c'est pas
grethen berck c'est principalement
l'histoire du développement durable
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
du matériel que vous avez qui est vendu
dans le commerce est vendu avec du
logiciel propriétaire
je vais prendre un exemple j'ai acheté
récemment du coup ce ce boîtier là donc
c'est une à une prise connecté en
bluetooth qui vous permet de pouvoir
contrôler derrière l'appareil que vous
allez branché et de contrôle et du coup
l'électricité qui passaient d'ailleurs
quand est ce que tu veux tu arrêter
quand est ce que tu veux te détendre et
du coup j'ai contacté un moment donné le
constructeur de cette fameuse prise et
je lui ai dit ok j'aimerais bien du coup
ap le gué ma propre ma propre
application at on à ton matériel pour
pouvoir contrôler du coup comme je veux
au final la prise et non pas via
l'application que tu as mis sur les
stores et le fabricant il m'a répondu ah
bah non c'est pas possible
moi je te donne pas je donne pas la
possibilité de le faire je dois pas les
accès parce qu'on est justement ceux du
logiciel propriétaire et c'est assez
flippant parce que ça veut dire quoi se
dire que le jour où la boîte est met la
clé sous la porte
ça ça file à la dèche est direct en fait
on peut pas leur cycle et vous ferez ce
que les cercles peut-être le plastique
en tant que telle la prison ça nous fait
une mini rallonge on va dire de 2 5 cm
mais en fait concernant la partie
logicielle en tant que tel mais on peut
rien en faire
donc derrière c'est la dèche est il ya
tout un paquet comme ça de matériel qui
est bon à jeter à la poubelle tout
simplement parce que les fabricants ils
ont mis la clé sous la porte et la
partie logicielle n'est plus du tout
accessible et la quatrième raison pour
laquelle on devrait tous du coup
commencé à faire le nettoyage dans
toutes ces solutions
c'est un petit peu tout là toutes les
parties révolte qu'on voit actuellement
que ce soit ici les gilets jaunes où que
ce soit n'importe quelle manifestation
généralement prem de fond c'est quoi
c'est qu'il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses de l'état
et pourquoi il ya plus d'argent dans les
caisses de télé de tabac tout simplement
parce que notre économie en tout cas une
grande partie notre économie elle tourne
sur la technologie dégâts femmes donc
aujourd'hui quand on ne serait ce que
vous regardez autour de vous que vous
rentrez dans un bus ou dans un lieu
public mairie que les gens sont
physiquement avec vous mais une grande
partie 2 sont aussi présents dans
l'univers du digital via leur smartphone
via leur ordinateur portable est en
train d'utiliser des technologies dégâts
femmes donc les gars femmes sont en
train de se mettre
de l'argent de poche et du coup plus on
va continuer à utiliser ces fameux
technologie plus du coup notre économie
va s'appauvrir aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'autre manière de faire que justement
de se mettre autour de son ordinateur de
développer ensemble avec tous les autres
pays
justement ces fameuses briques en
logiciels libres et de se mettre
progressivement à construire notre
propre infrastructure numérique
donc voilà tout ça c'était c'est un
petit peu flippant voyons maintenant un
petit peu comment on rentre dans cet
univers du logiciel libre
alors j'ai identifié quatre principales
manières de pouvoir rentrer dans cet
univers du logiciel libre et elles sont
toutes complémentaires
la première c'est vraiment de réaliser
et ça c'est assez dur à moi de les
réaliser au bout de vraiment au bout de
dix ans c'est de réaliser qu'on est
mauvais c'est à dire de réaliser que la
raison pour laquelle on n'utilise pas
ces logiciels c'est principalement parce
que la première fois qu'on les ouvre ou
qu'on les a lancés il ya un message
d'erreur qui s'est présentée à nous en
fait c'est pas vraiment un message
d'erreur ce cas c'est qu'un logiciel
libre il peut être configuré de mille et
une manières possibles et inimaginables
et ce cas c'est que si on n'a pas
compris justement qu'on peut le
configurer de manière différente et
qu'on doit le configurer en fonction de
nos besoins
il éclaire net qu'on va jamais réussir à
le trouver suffisamment instinctif
comparer un logiciel justement à
propriétaire est déjà bien défini parce
que son fabricant a souhaité faire donc
ça c'est vraiment la première chose à
faire deuxième c'est d'accepter
d'investir et d'investir jld c'est pas
forcément de l'argent c'est d'investir
du temps c'est de se dire que de la même
manière que lorsqu'on construit pour la
première fois sa maison la première fois
qu'on se met à je dirais innover dans
son appartement dans sa maison bah il
est clair et net que le premier trou que
vous avez percée dans le mur ce n'était
pas forcément un succès d' accord à des
choses que vous n'êtes pas mais très
bien là c'est la même chose il va
falloir accepter justement de passer du
temps régulièrement essayer de
comprendre qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
ordinateur
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un site web
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet tout
simplement parce que vous allez
continuer à utiliser de plus en plus ces
machines et si vous laissez au final les
gars femme vous bouffer et continue à
vous imposer un petit peu l'oreille vous
n'arriverez pas à comprendre tout
l'univers qui tourne autour
la troisième chose à faire c'est de
construire c'est à dire que vous pouvez
pas vous en sortir
si vous manipulez pas si vous créez pas
c'est à dire que quel que soit votre
profil
il va falloir un moment donné que vous
acceptiez de
lancée dans la création de votre propre
site web dans la création de vos propres
classeur numérique vous pouvez pas
imaginer le nombre de start-up pour qui
j'étais et que pour qui j'ai travaillé
qui sont pourtant des des fleurons de
l'industrie française voire même
européenne est le premier réflexe
kizomba en fait c'est chouette on
voudrait un google drive et on va [ __ ]
tous les documents de l'entreprise
dessus c'est cool c'est génial comme ça
t'en vois tout est secret de fabrication
directement à google et comment tu veux
derrière au final que ne serait-ce que
la france ou l'europe en fait arriva à
sortir des champions c'est pas possible
puisque de base
c'est ce que tu es en train de faire je
sais pas tant enseignants et enseignants
tu prends un google drive et tu mets les
notes de tout et étudiants du coup à
l'intérieur d'un classeur dans ce prix
de chine il se passe quoi il se passe
que le jour où google il veut recruter
est-ce qu'il a accès en effet à
l'ensemble des notes des étudiants s qui
sait qu'ils sont les meilleurs profils
bellouet esquissait qui sont les mauvais
bah oui le sait également en fait c'est
juste de la logique c'est à chaque fois
de vous dire j'utilise tel logiciel à
qu'ils appartiennent et au final est ce
que ces logiciels ils ont intérêt à un
moment donné de venir piocher dedans et
d'analyser ce qui se passe donc voilà ça
c'est justement la partie la partie
construction c'est vraiment il faut que
vous construisez vos propres trucs et en
effet c'est un combat un petit peu de
tout les jours quoi monter son propre
serveur s'est jamais fun moi ça me
faisait flipper que c'est un mais au
final avec le temps on y arrive et les
quatrièmes choses et qui est selon moi
également un des facteurs de succès du
logiciel libre c'est de partager
en fait c'est de contribuer c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi ces logiciels
paraissent un petit peu instinctif tout
simplement parce que toute la
documentation qui est accessible en
ligne et mises en ligne justement par
les personnes qui ont créé ces fameux
logiciel et eux ils sont de l'univers du
technique donc naturellement si pour
ceux et celles qui sont pas l'univers
technique vous vous expliquer pas vous
quels sont les freins que vous avez
rencontré si vous expliquez pas vous à
d'autres personnes si vous prenez pas
soin d ancienne génération
comment voulait justement que ces
anciennes générations arrivent aussi à à
passer le cap et arriver à comprendre
comment les utiliser et les manipuler et
en fait c'est l'effort que j'ai fait du
coup cet été j'ai accepté par exemple de
pas me payer pendant deux mois et
pendant deux mois j'ai créé du coup
cette fameuse plateforme pour mes
semblables quand je dis mes semblables
c'est les profils ans en marketing ce
qu'on appelle la floss marketing school
et l'objectif justement cette forme et
gratuitement librement tous les profils
en marketing digital voire même tout
individu à travers
monde sur justement l'utilisation de ces
fameuses technologie mais à des fins de
marketing digital
comment au lieu d'utiliser le moteur de
recherche google on peut créer aussi son
propre moteur de recherche et on peut
arriver à comprendre le fonctionnement
d'un moteur de recherche même chose qui
concerne tout ce qui va avec l'analyse
d'audience où un e-mailing et c'est avec
cet arrêt c'est ce fameux projet que
j'écris et pour conclure je vais vous
montrer simplement quelque chose de tout
simple ah c'est une maison cette maison
a été construite en fait part par mon
grand-père un qui nous a quittés du coup
il ya il ya deux ans et en fait lors de
la cérémonie d'adieu
la prêtresse a dit la chose suivante
elle a dit qu'il avait souhaitée du coup
passé ces derniers jours ces dernières
heures dans la maison qu'il avait
construite de ses propres mains et cette
phrase là m elle m'a marqué parce que
mon grand père il était pas maçon en
fait il était dessinateur industriel et
je pense que cela doit être un peu le
même cas pour pour pour vous pour ceux
qui ont des grands-parents
c'est de se dire que en fait à l'après
guerre il y avait tout à reconstruire
quoi et même si ce n'était pas le
travail de nos grands-parents barisis
sont allées du coup au charbon ils ont
appris justement à à prendre soin d'un
jardin à créer un mur à choisir les bons
qu'opposants et à faire avec ce qu'ils
avaient pour au final construire la
maison est aujourd'hui la situation
qu'on a c'est la suivante c'est nous on
a un univers qui était plutôt favorable
et pour construire notre univers basse
et c'est un simple ordinateur et
aujourd'hui on a peur de notre
ordinateur parce qu'au premier message
des ordres ou là c'est trop technique
j'ai besoin du coup d'appeler un
développeur et voilà pour terminer je
voulais simplement vous dire qu'en fait
d'un autre futur votre futur il effaça
vous en fait tous les jours c'est votre
écran d'ordinateur
il reste plus qu'à vous de de le changer
cette urne merci à vous
[Applaudissements]